si continuamos con nuestro modelo de vor
lo siguiente que vamos a analizar son
los diferentes niveles de energía así
que en este vídeo hablaremos de energía
nuevamente haremos muchas deducciones
usando física por lo que pueden saltarse
hasta el siguiente vídeo para ver qué es
lo que encontramos en este vídeo y como
se aplica tenemos que hablar de energía
y lo primero es la energía cinética del
electrón y sabemos que la energía
cinética es igual a un medio por m por b
al cuadrado donde m es la masa del
electrón ive es la velocidad así que si
el electrón va en esta dirección
alrededor del núcleo esta carga negativa
es nuestro electrón el vector velocidad
es tangente a este punto y sabemos que
este electrón es atraído por el núcleo
tenemos un protón en el núcleo del átomo
de hidrógeno en el modelo de vor y de
acuerdo a este modelo
sabemos que hay cierto radio asociado a
la posición de este electrón y como
sabemos que el electrón es atraído por
el núcleo
habrá una fuerza eléctrica este
electrones atraído por el núcleo por la
fuerza eléctrica la fuerza centrípeta
que mantiene al electrón en esta órbita
alrededor del núcleo en un vídeo
anterior hablamos de la magnitud de esta
fuerza eléctrica lo que necesitaremos
también en este vídeo pues lo vamos a
usar para calcular la energía cinética
del electrón la fuerza eléctrica está
dada por la ley de colom y la magnitud
de la fuerza eléctrica es igual acá que
es una constante que multiplica a q1 que
es la carga del protón que a su vez
multiplica q2 que es la carga del
electrón y todo esto está dividido entre
r al cuadrado y r es la distancia entre
nuestras dos cargas de acuerdo a la
segunda ley de newton la fuerza es igual
a la masa multiplicada por la
aceleración y como estamos hablando del
electrón pues va a ser la masa del
electrón multiplicada por la aceleración
del electrón la fuerza eléctrica es una
fuerza centrípeta que mantiene un
movimiento circular
así que podemos decir que esta es la
aceleración centrípeta vamos a escribir
lo que conocemos acá es una constante q
no es la carga de un protón que sabemos
es una carga elemental por lo que será
positiva por lo que será una positiva q
2 es la carga en el electrón que es la
misma carga del protón pero con valor
negativo así que tenemos menos y todo
esto dividido entre r al cuadrado que es
igual a la masa del electrón por su
aceleración centrípeta que es la
velocidad al cuadrado entre r ya hicimos
esto en un vídeo anterior y vamos a
hacer lo mismo en esta ocasión solo nos
interesa la magnitud de la fuerza
eléctrica pues ya sabemos que la
dirección siempre será hacia el núcleo
por lo tanto no nos interesa este signo
negativo de acá también podemos cancelar
una de estas eres así que como sólo nos
interesa la magnitud de este lado nos
queda acá x al cuadrado entre r es igual
a m
volver al cuadrado y podemos ver que
estamos casi donde queremos nuestra meta
es llegar a una expresión para la
energía cinética que sea un medio por m
por b al cuadrado y aquí ya tenemos m
por ver al cuadrado si multiplicamos a
ambos lados por un medio ahora tenemos
la expresión para la energía cinética
del electrón pues un medio por m por b
al cuadrado es igual a la energía
cinética así que sabemos que la energía
cinética es igual a un medio por k por e
al cuadrado entre r regresaremos más
adelante a la energía cinética ahora
vamos a calcular la energía potencial de
este electrón la energía potencial nos
la da esta fórmula en física la energía
potencial eléctrica es igual acá la
misma acá que multiplica a 1
es la carga del protón que multiplicada
q 2 que es la carga del electrón todo
dividido entre la distancia que lo
separa nuevamente esto es sólo física
vamos a escribir lo que conocemos
esto es igual acá uno es la carga del
protón que es positivo y q2 es la carga
del electrón que es menos es todo
dividido entre r en esta ocasión vamos a
dejar el signo negativo y es por la
forma en que definimos la energía
potencial así que tenemos que es menos k
por el cuadrado entre r y definimos
nuestra energía potencial igual a 0
cuando eres infinita también necesitamos
mantener el signo negativo porque es
importante ahora ya tenemos la energía
potencial eléctrica y también la energía
cinética y para encontrar la energía
total asociada al electrón este será
igual a la energía cinética más la
energía potencial vamos a agregar lo que
sabemos la energía cinética un medio de
k por iu al cuadrado entre r backing y
la energía potencial que encontramos
menos k por al cuadrado entre r
va acá y ahora podemos calcular la
energía total así que la energía total
es igual a un medio por acá por e al
cuadrado entre r que es la expresión de
la energía cinética más un valor
negativo escribimos menos acá por al
cuadrado entre él desde el punto de
vista matemático tendríamos un medio
menos 1 lo que nos daría menos un medio
que es menos un medio por cada x al
cuadrado entre r
que es nuestra expresión para la energía
total asociada con el electrón ahora
calculemos la energía total cuando el
radio es igual a r 1 como lo vimos en el
vídeo pasado la energía del electrón
cuando se encuentra en el estado
fundamental y quedamos que ese radio es
igual a 5.3 por 10 a la menos 11 metros
vamos a sustituir esta r en la fórmula
para calcular la energía total asociada
con este nivel de energía recuerden que
encontramos este valor de r haciendo
algunos cálculos y diciendo en igual a 1
y usando nuestra ecuación rn igual a n
al cuadrado por ere 1 cuando en es igual
a 1 la ponemos aquí y obtenemos nuestro
radio usamos este valor para hacer los
cálculos la energía total asociada con
el primer nivel de energía cuando en es
igual a 1
uno es igual a menos un medio por acá
que es 9 por 10 a la 9 x la carga
elemental en que es la magnitud de la
carga en un protón o en un electrón y es
igual a 1.6 por 10 a la menos 19 coloms
lo elevamos al cuadrado y todo esto es
dividido entre el radio que es 5.3 por
10 a la menos 11 metros y para
ahorrarnos tiempo no haré todos los
cálculos aquí pero si ustedes hacen los
cálculos verán que la energía asociada
al nivel fundamental del átomo de
hidrógeno es igual a menos 2.17 por 10 a
la menos 18
jules
si hacen el análisis dimensional de todo
esto pero aunque nos quedan jules este
es el estado de menor energía el estado
fundamental la energía es negativa
veremos el significado de este signo
negativo en el siguiente vídeo podemos
generalizar esta energía y podemos decir
que aquí lo hicimos para cuando en es
igual a 1 pero podemos decir que la
energía total para cualquier nivel de
energía m es y aquí vamos a poner r sub
n vamos a reescribir esta ecuación para
generalizar y decir que la energía en
cualquier nivel de energía es igual a
menos un medio capone al cuadrado entre
r m ahora podemos tener esta ecuación de
aquí de la cual hablamos y le dijimos en
otro vídeo y poner esto en nuestra r n
hacemos más espacio nos queda el m es
igual a menos un medio
de capone al cuadrado entre n al
cuadrado por el re 1 lo que calculamos
lo ponemos aquí abajo esto es lo mismo
que menos un medio por cada x al
cuadrado entre r uno por uno entre n al
cuadrado
acabo de reescribir esto de esta manera
particular porque ya sé aquí es igual
esto pues acabamos de calcularlo si
vemos aquí arriba esto es menos un medio
de capone al cuadrado entre r que es la
energía asociada al primer nivel de
energía podemos poner este número aquí
n es igual a menos 2 puntos 17 por 10 a
la menos 18 entre n al cuadrado y
podemos escribir esto de otra forma
también podemos decir que esto es igual
a 1 y para que la fórmula se vea más
pequeña
podemos decir que m es igual a 1
/ n al cuadrado cualquiera de estas
fórmulas es correcta podríamos
escribirla así o podemos escribir la así
en el siguiente vídeo usaremos esta
ecuación para calcular las diferentes
energías asociadas a los diferentes
niveles de energía pondremos un valor de
n y encontraremos su energía respectiva
la energía es cuántica da lo cual es un
concepto importante y es por eso que es
interesante estudiar el modelo de board
pues nos da estos niveles de energía
cuántica 2 que nos ayudan a explicar
algunas cosas que veremos en próximos
vídeos en el siguiente vídeo hablaremos
de energía usaremos esta fórmula y
veremos el modelo de board del átomo de
hidrógeno